[MUSIC PLAYING]
EVAN BROWN: Hello.
I'm Evan, and I'm an
engineer at Google.
DAN WENDORF: And hi.
I'm Dan, an engineer at Pivotal.
EVAN BROWN: Google and Pivotal
have been working together
the better part of this year.
DAN WENDORF: Sorry, Evan.
It's the best part of this year.
EVAN BROWN: I agree.
We've been working to bring
Cloud Foundry to Google Cloud
Platform.
And a lot of folks on
both sides were involved.
Today, Dan and I are going to
talk about some of that work.
DAN WENDORF: And we'll have
more videos in the coming
weeks featuring other
engineers from both Pivotal
and Google talking in depth
about service brokers, logging,
and monitoring.
But for today, it's me and
you talking to the internet
about BOSH and Cloud Foundry.
Evan, you picked up some
work earlier this year
to bring BOSH to GCP.
Can you talk a little
bit more about that?
EVAN BROWN: Sure.
BOSH is a lot of things,
but our initial focus
was really simple, and
that was to make it talk
to Google's infrastructure.
We made that work
pretty quickly.
We achieved that goal, and
then we set loftier goals.
We wanted Google to
be the best place
for BOSH to deploy
applications to,
especially things
like Cloud Foundry.
So those lofty goals that we
set included adding support
for Google's global network,
their global load balancer,
and 30-second VM boot
times, live migration,
and preemptable VM pricing,
just to name a few.
DAN WENDORF: And this work,
you did at all with Pivotal
and it's open source?
EVAN BROWN: That's
right, all with Pivotal.
We spent a lot of time here
in San Francisco with Pivots
like yourself.
The work that we've done has
been on GitHub since day one.
I think we hit a lot
of those lofty goals.
And I'd like to show
you by spinning up
a BOSH director on
GCP and setting it up
to deploy some software.
DAN WENDORF: All
right, sounds great.
EVAN BROWN: So I'm starting
inside the GCP console.
And I've got access
to a terminal here.
And the terminal, it's
called Cloud Shell.
And it's basically
a free VM where
I can do things like
deploy the infrastructure
that BOSH needs to run.
So we're using Terraform
to do this deployment.
It's provisioning all
of the networking that's
required for BOSH to run.
And we've got this handy
architecture diagram
that basically shows the bits
that are there for BOSH to run.
The most important thing is that
we would have a BOSH director.
And that BOSH director is going
to have a private IP address.
So it's not sitting on
the public internet,
but it is able to talk
to the public internet
through a NAT instance.
To talk to the BOSH director
directly, we have a bastion VM.
So you're able to SSH
into the bastion VM
or use SSH agent forwarding
to do things like BOSH target
and BOSH deploy.
So we use Terraform to provision
all of this infrastructure.
We do that from
within Cloud Shell.
And once we're inside
our BOSH bastion VM,
we can use BOSH-init to stand
up that first BOSH director.
This takes a little bit longer
than we're showing in the demo
here.
We've sped it up for time
purposes, but at this point,
we've got that global network.
We have our BOSH
director up and running.
And we would be able
to deploy Cloud Foundry
or Concourse or any other
BOSHified application.
And Dan, I know you work on
Cloud Foundry at Pivotal.
And you did a lot of work
to make it run really
well on Google Cloud Platform.
So would you be able to talk
a little bit about that work?
DAN WENDORF: Sure.
One of Cloud Foundry's
biggest selling points
is its ability to run great
and many cloud platforms,
abstracting away boring
details, while really exposing
what makes a platform unique.
To get it running
great on Google,
our engineers dove
into the infrastructure
to really understand
its ins and outs
and to figure out where
Cloud Foundry needed
to change to run perfectly.
So we spent a lot
of time focusing
on networking configuration
to get the fast and solid
networking that
Google's known for
and bringing in other
services like Google Cloud
Storage for native blob stores.
EVAN BROWN: Very cool.
There's a link below where
you can follow a tutorial
to deploy open-source Cloud
Foundry on the Google Cloud
Platform.
But Dan, I know there
are other ways to get up
and running with Cloud
Foundry on Google.
Could you talk a
little bit about that?
DAN WENDORF: Yeah, totally.
Cloud Foundry's a highly
customizable platform,
even down to how it's deployed.
On our doc site at
docs.pivotal.io,
there's tons of information
about how you can configure
every part of your
deployment with BOSH if you'd
like more control.
But if you're looking for
something a little bit
more hands off, we've got
Pivotal Cloud Foundry--
or PCF-- which comes
with Ops Manager.
It's an appliance that
lives in your Google project
and can manage a lot of
this deployment for you.
EVAN BROWN: Very cool.
Thanks, everyone, for watching.
Be sure to check out the
tutorials in the description.
And stay tuned for the next
videos in this series where
other Pivotal and Google
engineers will talk about tools
they built including service
broker integrations, logging,
and monitoring for
BOSH and Cloud Foundry
on Google Cloud Platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey!
Be sure to check out this video
of my colleague Vic showing you
how to deploy a global,
multiregion Cloud Foundry
installation.
And look at the playlist for
other videos in this series.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Cloud channel.